[Music]  surprise Anna Kournikova and Enrique  Iglesias are first-time parents the  longtime couple welcomed twins over the  weekend a boy and a girl according to  TMZ the outlet adds that the babies who  were born in Miami are named Nicholas  and Lucy the newborns are the first  children for both the singer and the  retired tennis star who have been  together for over a decade and a half  the two who are rarely photographed  together have managed to keep their  relationship extremely private but in  August Kournikova did share a clip to  Instagram showing off her fitness in a  baggy shirt little did we know she was  hiding a baby bump